[Music]
hello I'm John Garvey
director and I'm here with Sam Witwer I
play deacons st. John and they's gone
yeah and we're here to talk about the
alternate path demo so we did two demos
for you three the chairs on highway 1
you guys saw at the media showcase and
this one we showed behind closed doors
on on the floor at e3 and so for the
first time we're releasing it online so
that everybody can kind of take a look
at it I thought I'd just talk a little
bit about you know what the differences
are and just kind of like to show you
what we were trying to accomplish this
year yeah I mean the most obvious
difference so far is its last one is
night time during the rain and this is
day time during the snow yeah and that
you know that and it's not just cosmetic
and I think that's one of the things we
really wanted to emphasize you know
because this time we're showing sort of
a day in the life of deacon he's on the
drifter bike here we wanted to show a
little more of the bike riding and how
the weather can kind of impact that so
we have this drifting mechanic right you
see him kind of slipping and sliding
around a little bit the handling because
I it's really interesting now there were
wolves there last time Johnny these
wolves would pursue you down this road
and then he can have the turns back
shoot a wolf and you got clothes on
right out there yeah Denis yeah exactly
so this time you see that he wasn't
being chased by the lulls that's a
dynamic event that can just that just
you know it's just a that could happen
or not just depends on when you're
playing the game interesting and this
time Deacon saw the ambush and he was
able to avoid it so he kind of comes up
and around and behind so does weather
impacts whether these creatures show up
or not in daytime nighttime all that
yeah absolutely so especially the
freaker's they come out they're mostly
nocturnal but they will come out as the
weather gets colder they become stronger
in the cold and so that will you know
again kind of change up the way the game
plays that's very very i kind of love
that you decided to do this as a demo to
show two completely different iterations
on the same exact mission in the game
yes exactly so we wanted to have you
know this the job is basically the same
Deacon hears that his buddies in trouble
rides out to save his life and you know
as you can see here this is a completely
different experience from what we showed
in the first demo on the first one
Deacon gets clotheslined in sound
painful by the way that was speaking of
painful okay so where the combat in this
one is fairly brutal John you want to
talk about that well we just wanted to
make it as you know as realistic as
possible so yeah we're not holding back
on that at all
um and you know it's hems done most of
your zones don't work for this and I can
tell you that when we're on the
performance stage and we're capturing
that stuff we just try to make keep it
real right right right well right there
was sort of a decision made at some
point and what we even weren't I've been
where I've been on the project for what
two or three years now yeah I think
three years and and so early on I think
there was a more or we it was more Kurt
Russell and sort of a two-fisted thing
and then it turned into hey let's take
this quite seriously and what that
required is a lot more taking this
combat stuff and showing the horror of
the violence that happens and and it
were this type of circumstance to take
players I mean realism weirdly enough is
a thing we keep going back to when it
comes to the it's not just the stunts
but also the performance style I think
you know it's very important that
doesn't seem like a bunch of actors you
know saying line two is a very
incidental and we want you know we
wanted the world to sort of reflect that
as well I saw there that you know Deacon
broke into that emergency vehicle what's
good a talisman supplied so this is what
we're calling our survival visions or so
I saw that earlier when he was looking
at Manny's bike on the ground and it's
just kind of a way of seeing tracks in
the world and sort of imagining what
might have happened and here I just
wanted to point out that you're seeing
in this part of the demo that there are
freaker's there there weren't there
before yes it wasn't snowing it was you
know it was getting lighter out it
wasn't getting darker like it is and so
you know it changes up the way you can
play through the level and what is this
we called up some meat walk the meat
walk yeah it's not just there you know
to you know make the guys who put them
up to pristine evil they're there for a
purpose because again freaker's are
living creatures they eat that's our
primary that's their primary thing they
want to eat and so you hang these dead
freaker's up and it you know and anybody
any creature rather than coming into
their camp like you see here they would
actually just stop and snack yeah
exactly and then the same thing with
this freak er that they've hung upside
down
there's a bear trap underneath it and
they use that because a frico will come
be attracted to the meat and then hit
that hit that trap interesting no
nothing you just saw by the way is it
that tin can and trappings yeah that's a
little arm that the Marauders will put
up and this is again some of the things
that Marauder camps just do you find
these Marauder camps throughout the
world you'll find traps like that and
then if you're careful and you're paying
attention you can avoid them because in
the first demo he can didn't avoid it
and he set off that alarm right now now
this is the same tactic in these last
times rows the rocket gets someone to
lure it lure Moberg having stuff in the
bait traps but this one plays out a
little bit differently than last time
one of the things that struck me and we
talked about this obviously as we've
shot but there's there's an effort of
the other Marauders to get this guy to
shut up and he won't yeah and so in the
in the first demo you Deacon's hitting
on down the trail and you can hear that
happening behind him right and this time
we're showing what happened so you know
he's watching everybody reacted this
poor guy trapped in the you know not
bear trap and she just was like shut up
shut up shut up and then just loses it
and shoots the guy right right and of
course in the meantime Deacon you know
scrapping them all on top and just takes
them all up for this now
so yeah so again it's like in the
previous demo dem Deacon would have gone
off to the trail down to the right this
time he's going to head this way he
follows the tracks
ah and comes under a sniper attack now
let me ask you something about the
survival okay this is sniper tech coming
but of the survival vision is if you
don't say upgrade your survival vision
can you miss Clewes i mean other things
that you would get a few upgrades your
survival vision like that would help you
complete the mission exactly
and you have to you know we have a whole
skill tree and it's all tied to
experience that you can earn as you're
just playing through the game and then
you can upgrade those what's happening
here we had a freak er tied to a tree
yeah so this is another type of trap
that Marauders will set they will set
you know they will basically chain
freaker's to the perimeter of their
camps and they use them as kind of an
alarm system and then that you know you
saw that Marauder there he was just
tormenting the poor Freaker and then so
he can kind of take the takes advantage
of that
well would you think for a moment if
Deacon is the guys he's sort of helping
the Freaker by you know getting the guy
that taunted him is but no no and then
he's gonna take a freak her out right
afterwards exactly and this is a bit of
a silent sniping using the crossbow yeah
so this whole sequence at the end plays
out very differently in the first demo
you saw he can use a swarm you
weaponized a swarm lured them into the
camp and then they kind of did the work
for him there's no swarm in this
run-through so the player really has to
go in and use what we're calling our
strategic sandbox combat and that's just
you know stealth mechanics and setting
and using traps whole arsenal of weapons
you see there's a variety of weapons
that you can is getting used to it's
including a crossbow he crafts his own
bolts and you know he's got it he's got
to figure out how to get up to Manny
just you know using his combat skills
right instead of doing it strategically
so straightening out those bonfires
where those are there in the previous
denim no they weren't right so that's
another big difference is that if you
come here during the day you know it's
like in the media showcase demo there
was like kind of a Fight Club thing
going right they were they were punching
each other and everybody was just sort
of getting into a nobody jeweler pig I
don't know what they went on and now
it's getting dark and it's cold out so
you know they've built these bonfires so
you know and again it just did it's not
just a cosmetic change in the way the
whole it's cold we I would say because
they have to build some
so it changed the way the the Marauders
behaved in the love that's very again
this is part of the reason why I love
that you did this as a demo because the
the behavior of all of these things not
just the freaker's but the Marauder is
everything there's a logic to it you can
track why they're doing the things that
they're doing and you can use it to your
advantage in the game class that's kind
of what I like about this so much and
that's really what we wanted to show
faces here is that it's an open world
game and you know everything you see
around here and again we're only playing
is two different ways
you saw that waterfall way up there off
in the distance there's a bridge that
goes in front of that if you had a
sniper rifle on enough ammunition you
could have driven your bike all the way
up there there's drills go all the way
up there and you could use your sniper
rifle to take out this entire camp
because it would have taken them a while
to figure out where the shots were
coming from and to get to you so you
know that's a different way to play
there's another way to play by the way
where you could have just stealth in
through the entire camp if you have the
skills to do it and you could have just
taken everybody out silently or almost
everybody and then you could have gotten
up to where Manny is being held using a
different route and you know just
stealth killed that guy there's no
reason that you have to come in and run
a gun like like D guys doing here how
scarce is ammunition because I see him
switching from a bunch of weapons and I
when we saw this demo when I when I came
in so d3 one of the things that I that I
really enjoyed was I was sitting next to
you and the driver was playing the game
and at some point I saw you shifting
your chair and you leaned forward and I
heard you say oh man oh I'm like what
what's going on he's like he's gonna get
killed
whoa oh and I lead for I was like I
guess there's a real danger and one of
the things was that he was running out
of ammunition and he was trying to go
pick up ammo from the dead I was looking
for a murder but but I was either
involved we were in three we had a whole
team with us and everybody played it
slightly differently so it just shows
you that it's not scripted at all yeah
um and then this rage your bear yeah the
infected bear infected bear that's yeah
yeah that's not what you want to see
well that we thought
would be a good way to end the demo is
to show that it's just what the Deacons
life is just one darn thing ever
yeah right you're going to save your
buddy you get clothesline you get
attacked by wolves or you know you think
you're finally done you rescued your you
know you've gone through all the stuff
and then suddenly raid your back right
well as as you said to me it's not just
about exploring it up a world as it is
the open world coming after you the open
world seeking you out trying to yeah
exactly that's our tagline um the intake
on you don't have to go seeking out
trouble the world comes trouble is
looking for you
alright Sam thanks a lot thanks John and
fun and hope you guys enjoyed the demo
and we'll talk more about it
today's been